[Music]
so I'm Paul Nash I'm the product lead
for compute engine and I have with me
today Michael Crandall CEO and founder
of RightScale he'll be up in a little
bit so today we wanted to talk about
Google's approach to cloud pricing in
general and how we think about customers
and what we try to optimize for in
building products and then specifically
for compute engine we want to talk about
the customer friendly pricing features
that we've come up with that we think
are really a great way to use the cloud
then we're going to talk a little bit
about how beyond that set of features
and discounts there are some other
things you can do to tune your workload
to save even more money and then finally
we'll have Michael up to show some
real-world examples using customer data
of what that looks like on paper and
then we'll take your questions as well
or you can all run away and have beer
and find either way so Google's approach
to cloud starts with Google's approach
to customers in general and one of the
things that I mean about that is we have
a set of core values at Google about key
principles like data security privacy
and above all user trust so we believe
that maintaining our users and customers
trust in Google is looking out for their
best interests as one of our highest
callings so additionally our goal is to
build products that are simple to use
and well designed and this includes how
you pay for them so what that boils down
to on compute engine is really three
core pricing philosophy principles that
we use to think about how we're pricing
and how we're building discounts the
first is it should be simple so no
rocket science
no PhDs in economics no ministries of
pricing within your companies as we're
said this morning and no hidden costs
second it should be flexible and what
that means is you pay for what you use
apparently the whole point of cloud is
to be elastic
right well some things are more elastic
than others and so for that to be true
the pricing can't rope the developers
into a certain shape of what you're
using or how long you have to use it for
what you can do with it and finally then
we think the real embodiment of user
customer trust is the idea that prices
should be fair so we should start with
making prices low as low as we can and
then if we find ways to bring additional
savings into the ecosystem either
because we're scaling or because we got
a better hardware or we found some new
efficiencies in how our software is
managing that hardware you should get
those savings passed on to you as well
and that includes also the concept of
automatic discounts so if you use the
cloud in a way that is more efficient
for us we should pass those savings on
to you so what do I mean when I say
simplicity well this is a graphic that
one of our product managers came up with
it's a little faded out but this is a
screen capture of our pricing page sort
of laid sideways and one of the other
clouds pricing page is laid sideways so
it's a pretty obvious representation of
like how much do you have to ingest and
understand in order to figure out what's
going on how much am I paying I spend a
lot of time with these pages I'm sure
some of you have as well they're they're
lovely pages but what I find is that I
also spend a lot of time with Chrome's
search in Page feature to find where the
information is on that page that I'm
trying to understand how much is a
customer being charged for that and it's
not at all obvious that that is a good
use of my time in fact usually I don't
consider it is I usually end up building
spreadsheets in fact to break that
information apart and try to understand
it more wouldn't just be simpler if you
didn't have to do that and you can focus
on your application that's what we think
about
so one of the main ways that pricing can
get complicated is in how various is
resources are bundled together by some
of the providers so this creates dozens
of different pre-canned configurations I
call it alphabet soup which are
ostensibly optimized for different
classes of workloads and the problem is
as always that that requires a bunch of
generalizations and a bunch of
assumptions what if you need all the RAM
but you don't need all of the CPU or
what about that SSD that you got for
free in that VM are you using that
because it's not free so understanding
the basic combinations and all the sizes
that that can be kind of a full-time job
and trying to figure out for example
simple things like how much are you
paying for one of the CPUs in your
machine or for a gigabyte of RAM it's
hard to tell for sure and it's not
always the same and what's worse every
time they add a new generation of
hardware you get a whole new set of SKUs
to figure out this is a problem we
talked about internally called SKU
explosion so you have some giant page of
all the different price points and how
much everything costs and every time
there's a new discount model or a new
tweak or a new feature you get a whole
other set of those skills it's difficult
to manage it's difficult to understand
and so we try to find a better way so by
comparison we have one main family it's
called in one there's a couple very
special machine types called f1 and g1
but almost all of our usage and almost
all of our customers are using n1 we
might someday have a second family but
that's kind of a big decision for us so
we just have the one for now and what we
try to do with that is give you a
transparent price in performance so that
allows us to have as few SKUs as we
possibly can to understand in the first
place fewer things to understand the
better and with something like custom
machine types is actually only 2 there's
how much of CPU costs and how much does
RAM cost so that lets you buy just what
you need and you can use it however you
want either as one of our predefined
shapes or as a custom machine type
so with the custom machine types in the
predefined shapes we put some predefined
in there just so that it would be a
little bit easier to get started so
there's a couple typical ratios of RAM
to CPU that a lot of customers will find
adequate for most of their workloads but
you should just think of those as little
marks on the dials that you can use to
start if you want to start there that's
great if you don't you can build a
custom machine type and either way if
you find later that you're not using the
right amount of resources you can
optimize that easily in fact we even
will help you do that so a VM at its
essence of course is just that CPU and
RAM and anything else we view is an
add-on so another way that we try to
keep things simple and transparent is by
trying to not bundle in the different
pieces together and giving you an opaque
product that hides the different costs
of those various components so why do
the others do it this way well it's
easier but it's easier for them not for
you so pre configuring a Hardware
according to a fixed recipe that would
sure make it easier for us to manage our
fleet but it would make it it would make
you inherit the complexity so what would
end up happening is it you'd pay the
price because you're paying for things
you don't need and they'd all be bundled
together in whatever alphabet letter you
decided was the right VM for your
workload so we decided to keep our
prices visible and let you choose what
you need and then we'll take care of the
fleet efficiency behind the scenes using
Google magic so just to give you an
example of one of the things that tends
to get bundled in on some clouds is how
much does it cost to run Windows on a VM
well it turns out you can't really tell
unless you go back to that giant long
page and build a spreadsheet and crack
everything apart and once you do that
what you'll see is that depending on the
alphabet letter that you choose the cost
of windows per core is different
but that's kind of strange because the
costs for us to sell you a Windows
license per core doesn't change if we
run it on a faster or slower CPU or on
one that has more RAM or memory or disk
attached to it so on Google Cloud it's
always four cents per core per hour no
matter what so now I want to talk about
flexibility and that really means these
two concepts so pay for what you use and
buy only what you need it sounds simple
right
everybody does it yeah not so much
so everybody assumes that cloud is pay
as you use but it turns out that the way
that you count usage matters a lot in
practice so in GCE we've had permanent
billing from day one because at Google
we understand that workloads don't come
in hour-long chunks most of the time so
for example imagine that you had a set
of VMs Illustrated just below by this
bar chart that we're running for
differing periods of time and there are
a number of ways this could happen one
is it may be they're part of an auto
scaled workload and some of them are
only needed for a small amount of time
and some of them are needed for most of
the time that you're experiencing a
spike another way that this might happen
is if you're doing some batch processing
and there's a number of different tasks
being distributed to VMs and you need
some for a while and then others you
don't need for a while so movie
rendering might be a good example of
that where you don't know what the frame
time is going to be well if on the scale
at the left you have 0 to 60 minutes and
your workload takes the amount of time
in blue then all that stuff in the red
is wasted and in this particular
hypothetical example that's like 40
percent of what you're paying so this is
a slightly different scenario that we
modeled to illustrate what would happen
if you were using an auto scaled
workload so in this example the bar
charts are representing a set of VMs you
have where every VM can run 20 queries
per second and
let's imagine that this is a website and
a talk show host famous talk show host
has just mentioned our website on live
TV and we had this burst and everybody
wants to come and buy our widget so in
order to react to that scale you're
going to spin up something like 50 VMs
but here's the thing when you go to spin
those down whether you spin them down
right away or not if you're paying per
hour you're still paying for another
chunk of usage that's almost as big as
the spike itself in fact looks a little
bit bigger if you're paying per minute
it scales down much faster as the
traffic dies away and this graph doesn't
have to be blocky like it is here this
is just shown at five minute intervals
to give you an idea of what the steps
look like but in reality our autoscaler
at least resamples every 60 seconds so
it would follow that curve much more
smoothly so finally another key use case
that we see a lot so imagine that you
have a workload that takes about four
hours to run and it runs on a four core
machine currently now let's say you go
and do a bunch of optimization work and
you've got it to the point where you can
scale up that workload and you're
getting about a 1.8 X scaling factor it
could be 100 but it's not ever 2.0 if
you want to double the number of cores
you're not going to usually get exact
scaling so let's say that you get 1.8 X
so the graph on the Left shows what the
run times would change and how they
would change if you went to 8 cores 16
cores or 32 core machine under those
assumptions and the graph on the right
shows what you would pay if you were
paying per minute versus per hour so
what happens is the workload runtime
might fall below one of the hour marks
but you're still paying for the extra
waste and so all of your your work you
might have gotten your answer faster but
you're paying more for it - so this is
one of the key principles that we
believe is important in a truly elastic
cloud so next I want to talk about VM
sizes so why is it that machines are
sized in powers
- anyway you know we have an idea I'll
tell you why it's easier again though
it's easier for whoever's building the
cloud not for you the customer so
computer scientists in the room might
recognize this it's called a bin packing
problem and if you don't have powers of
two the concern is that it's harder to
make sure that all the processors on a
machine are filled and in use all the
time without leaving some behind well
turns out at Google we solve that
problem a long time ago because we built
our cloud 10 to 15 years ago and we have
lots of workloads - but we need to pack
them all in efficiently on processors
and so we built a system called Borg
that does that the further turns out
that when we went to go build our public
cloud we built it all on that same Borg
technology so underneath Google compute
engine is years of work from hundreds of
engineers figuring out how to solve that
problem without making you just pay for
the inefficiency so if I sell you power
of two sized machines like a 64 core
machine but you actually only need 40
cores the other 24 cores are wasted if
I'm the cloud provider doing that I
might not be concerned about it because
you're paying for it if I'm Google and
I'm building that cloud for myself
I'm concerned about it a lot because I'm
paying for it and it's a massive amount
of inefficiency so we get rid of all
that by using by offering you custom
machine types which are built on that
same infrastructure another advantage
that we've seen from this is that a lot
of customers over time have purchased
specific sized hardware and in an
on-premise fleet it's it's common to see
something like a 12 core machine that's
actually 12 physical cores so if they
want to move that to the cloud today
they'd have to buy a 16 core the EM in a
lot of places and that automatically
shifts the bill and makes the comparison
of costs difficult so if you have
something like custom machine types it's
fine for a customer to bring their bill
of materials their whole list of all the
different VM sizes and shapes
that they have on-prem today if they're
thinking about lifting and shifting a
workload you can simply configure a
custom machine type that matches those
sizes bring all your workload in and
then optimize when it's convenient for
you so we see customers do that a lot to
get a better match between what they're
going to use in cloud and what they're
using today on-premise in fact we
launched this feature out just a little
over a year ago and in that time it's
grown to be about 20% of our total usage
by core hours and in GCE and we went and
calculated the savings from what
customers would have had to spend if
they were using the next up standard
size and it turns out those customers
that are using it are saving about 19
percent on average simply by not over
buying so finally I want to talk about
fairness so one of the things we talk a
lot about with discounts is the number
what's the percentage there's a bunch of
numbers flying around some of the larger
some are smaller one of the things I
want to take a minute to stress is that
the discount is only one part of the
equation don't be fooled by a larger
number I'm sure we've all seen the
commercials where there's 20% off a sofa
but if the sofa was marked up 4,000
percent in the first place you might be
better off with the guy down the street
that's offering a low low everyday price
so it's a little bit like that you need
to look at factors like what's the list
price
what kind of flexibility are you giving
up to get the discounts what kind of
strings are attached and are you paying
for hidden things that you don't
actually need and more often than not
what we find is when people do that
whole calculation Google comes out ahead
in terms of what you save by default and
what you can save by making
optimizations to your usage so in 2014
when we launched Google cloud platform
we introduced a new way to bring
discounts to customers and we think it's
better way so when you use our vns
consistently it's more efficient for us
and we think our principle of fairness
means that when we save money because
you're using our cloud in a way that's
efficient for us you deserve to get that
back so that's what sustained use
discounts Dale and the nice thing about
that is that you still maintain all the
flexibility of an on-demand cloud and
you can start and stop your instances
whenever you want you can change your
usage pattern it's all up to you and
we'll just give you the best discount
that you usage qualifies for
automatically on a month-by-month basis
so one detail I want to mention here is
that there's actually two modes of
calculations for a sustained use
discounting if you want you can call
them s UD 1.0 and s UD 2.0 the first is
is the original sustained use discount
that we launched which is uses a concept
called inferred instances and I'm going
to talk about what that is in just a
minute the second is what we do with
custom machine types so when we launch
custom machine types the concept of
inferred instance is got a little
complicated because of custom machine
types you can essentially have thousands
of different shapes of machines and so
what inferred instances does is it
combines together usage of same shape
but now with custom machine types you
won't have same shaped so what we do
instead is we look at the total chunk of
CPUs and RAM that you use throughout the
month and we give you a similar discount
for sustained usage so just briefly what
what is an inferred instance this is
something we sometimes get questions
about so I wanted to explain a little
bit more so in this graphic imagine that
you're using some one core VMs and you
use five different instances at various
times in the month as is represented on
the left side on the Left graph to use
instance one for about half the month
sometime about the 10th of the month you
start instance two and then about
halfway through the month you start
three and four and five so on the
surface of it if you understand that
sustained use discounts the whole point
is we give you more discount for the
more you use it throughout the month it
doesn't necessarily look like you would
get a whole ton of discount because none
of those instances are being used for
very much of the month at all they would
get the first year for 25% usage but
maybe not much more so we didn't think
that was necessarily fair because
it doesn't matter much to our efficiency
if you run one instance here and then
shut it down for a while and then run
another instance the next day it's
exactly the same shape and run that for
the rest of the month so what we do is
we reimagine your usage pattern we
reinterpret it to look like the graph in
the middle so you can see we've flipped
the number three VM down and this is
just conceptual this is a big data
processing problem that our billing
system does automatically for you but
conceptually we've taken VM number three
and flipped it down as if it were part
of VM one and then we've aligned VMs two
and four and part of five as if they
were a second VM and then we've left the
rest of five as if it was a third VM so
now this graph on the right is what we
compute your discount on and it's much
bigger discount than you would have
gotten in the graph on the left so you
can see that it looks like you used one
inferred instance for the entire month
and then the second instance you used
for over half the month and then the
third instance you used for about a
quarter of the month so each of those
will get a different tier of su D but it
would be a much higher tier than you
would have gotten in combination on the
left so this is one of the ways that we
calculate what's the best deal for you
so we've had a sustained use discounts
in production for a few years now and
customers really like them and they're
getting a lot of savings out of them but
some of the conversations we've had is
is there any way you can give me a
better discount sustained use discount
it resets every month but many customers
say to us hey I know that I'm going to
use a certain amount of resources a
hundred percent of the time to run my
website and that's just getting bigger
every month so is there some way that
you can give me a better discount if I
tell you how much I'm going to use at a
minimum for the whole year or maybe
longer so that brings us to the question
of product we announced this morning
called committed use discounts
so basically the premise of the product
is if you knew and you could tell Google
that you were going to use a certain
minimum amount of resources all year
shouldn't you get a bigger discount
there's one obvious answer to that we
say yes so how does it work basically we
give you the best discounts we possibly
can if you agree to buy resources for
one year or for three but don't worry we
don't require any large upfront payments
you can pay us monthly that's cool we've
got 30 billion dollars we're spending on
infrastructure we don't need to charge
you all upfront your promise is good
enough for us so what we do with that
though is give you all the flexibility
so that you can make changes whenever
you want if you decide one day that
you're going to go into your application
code and optimize it and all of a sudden
you find a bug and it turns out that you
need 50% less compute than you thought
you did awesome change the instance
sizes keep on going and you'll still get
your discount additionally we don't
charge you any discount to get that
flexibility so some computing products
if you want to be able to invert them
you will lose some of the discount you
will not get the maximum discount and
that's not how ours works so how much so
four predefined machine types you'll get
37 percent off for one-year discount for
one-year commitment and for three years
you'll get 55 percent these numbers are
actually a little bit higher for a
custom machine type they're 40 and 57
respectively so the way that we make
that flexible is that the whole thing is
designed based on the underlying
resources so if you think back a minute
ago when I was talking about sustained
use discounts and how s UD 2.0 looks at
the number of cores and RAM that you've
used committed use discounts are the
same way so rather than trying to
predict how many machines you need of a
certain size in what zone just tell us
how much CPU and how much RAM and then
you can use those in any combination so
it sounds like we're asking you to tell
us more but it's actually simpler
because most customers already know that
math
additionally then like I said they're
not tied to any particular VM shape but
they're also not tied to any particular
VM instance itself so what we do is we
simply look at how much was running at
every moment in time every minute and we
take the first chunk of that and we give
you committed use discount on it but the
thing then is whatever's above that we
still give you permanent billing and
sustained use discount on all the rest
so there's no penalty to having a
committed use discount as long as that
is the minimum that you're going to be
using because you're still going to get
the full discounts on all the rest so if
you're not sure how much to buy start
small
see how your workload is running and
then you can increase over time if you
need to and you can know that you're
still getting a really competitive
discount on the rest of it so I built a
little example just to show you what
that looks like very simply in this
picture if you imagine that there's a
threshold where you have a certain
amount of committed use and then above
that you're getting sustained use you
can see where VM a is shut down for a
while and then comes back but what we've
done is said okay well for that period
of time the usage from VM e gets
committed use and then later it'll get
sustained use again and obviously this
can look like a much more complex
picture in reality so finally I want to
talk about some tuning some features you
can use to take advantage of tuning your
workloads so that it's best configured
to get the maximum savings on GCE
so the first feature is right-sizing
you've probably seen this we've talked
about it in a couple different places
the social media was had a kind of
common idea when we introduced this
features what are they crazy they're
telling me how to spend less money on
purpose yes we are so we would rather
that you optimize your infrastructure
usage for what your workload actually
needs rather than trying to optimize
your workload to fit in particular sized
infrastructure of ours and we would
rather that you buy what's valuable to
you and nothing more will happily sell
the rest of that to somebody else so
what this does is automatically monitors
your CPU and RAM usage from outside the
VM and if it sees that you never use
more than a certain amount of CPU will
recommend that you scale down the CPU if
you're never using more than a certain
amount of RAM we'll scale that down too
and it turns out as one additional
detail of this if you actually install
this the stack driver monitoring agent
then we get better memory information
and we can actually make a better
recommendation for you but either way
you'll get a good recommendation on what
kind of machine you want and then simply
all you need to do there is on the
right-hand side click that
recommendation and you can shut you need
to shut down and quickly restart your VM
in order to change the size it's just
that simple
finally I also want to talk about
preemptable VMs so the idea with
preemptable VMs is to offer a product is
as low cost as we can make it and
optimized for short term workloads so if
you have a large-scale fault tolerant
workload that can withstand a few of its
workers shutting down without losing too
much of your overall work then that's
probably a job that is really ideal for
preemptable VMs and if you use those
you'll find that there are almost 80%
off of list prices in some cases they
are 80% in some cases are a little bit
less the only restrictions are that
there's a maximum lifetime on that VM of
24 hours and there's a small probability
chance
that we might take back the VM early
will give you a short warning of about
30 seconds and say hey we need that back
so a lot of workload so you can see
there's a whole list of different ones
below are finding that that's a really
efficient way to get large amounts of
compute so one of my colleagues in a
room down the hall right now is talking
about an example where Fermilab ran
160,000 cores preemptable in order to
calculate higher energy physics
experiments and it actually doubled the
compute fleet of Fermi National
Accelerator Laboratory in finding exotic
new physics particles so it's just one
example of what you can do with
preemptable VMs in a very affordable way
but there's lots of other use cases from
genomics and gina genome sequencing to
computational chemistry fluid dynamics
etc so finally I want to talk a little
bit more about our Auto scale alright I
showed the graph earlier that talked
about how permanent billing helps but
there's actually some other features of
our autoscaler that helps save money too
so first of all the fact that it's
extremely fast and reactive to workloads
so unlike some other auto scalars we've
actually never had to consider building
a feature where you would either
schedule in advance for it to scale up
or pre-warm
VMS so it could react faster we kind of
feel like that's not what Auto is
supposed to mean so ours just scales and
because our VMs can do it in 30 seconds
or less we can actually react to spikes
very quickly up to millions of QPS and
what that means is you don't have to
have VM sitting around waiting or
running longer in case the spike comes
back you don't have to have them running
just in case there's a spike because you
never know what might happen in social
media you don't have to worry about any
of that and all of those VMs that might
be running handle scenarios like that
are just money you're wasting so just
the fact that our autoscaler works like
this actually saves you money as well
and you might even actually consider
whether workloads you might not think
our web server for example those
workloads might benefit from a fast
autoscaler and help you automatically
tune what you're using so that's a
number of the different pricing features
and discounts that are available on GCE
and now I'd like to invite Michael
Crandall is the CEO and founder of right
scale-up to show you what some of that
looks like in practice Oh Michael thank
you thanks very much Paul you know I
want it I wanted to start out by sharing
its pleasure to be here it's especially
exciting during this week of pretty
actually groundbreaking announcements
about pricing and innovative
announcements and I just wanted to share
that maybe for those of you here and
those online it's those of you who or
it's late on a Thursday it may be that
savings in cloud spend is not the most
exciting thing but I can share with you
that I guarantee the more you use cloud
and we hear this all the time pretty
soon as you start getting those bills
savings becomes a lot more interesting
in your organization and so I promise
that this is going to be meaningful
stuff a little background about us
the right scale at right scale we focus
on cloud management and ever since about
five years ago we acquired a small
startup that was focusing on a piece
called cloud cost management cloud cost
analytics we've seen increasing interest
in both the opportunity that can be
achieved through savings and the
challenge and so let's dive right in on
the challenge side we also run every
year a state of the cloud survey we get
about a thousand responses from
companies ranging from small businesses
to enterprise level companies and we ask
a bunch of questions and we ask one
about waste what do you think you're
wasting in your cloud spend I think
Earth's herzl shared that this morning
this stat but the self-reported waste in
other words the waste that people think
that's occurring is about 30 percent
we've found from our product and in
close
engagements with customers that often is
upwards of 40 up toward 45% so it's
pretty clear everyone agrees there is a
lot of waste and that also means there's
a lot of opportunity so I wanted to
share with you today from Wright scales
perspective in the field three of the
biggest areas that we see that are waste
out there and that are also
opportunities for savings and they focus
around these three areas one is not
taking advantage of discounts discount
structures that are available the second
is running workloads that don't need to
run all the time and still running them
24/7 and the last area is
over-provisioning right underutilized
instances and VMs that are running out
there and so we'd like to focus across
these three areas on three of the future
offerings that you've heard about today
some of them brand-new offerings
committed use and sustained use
discounts preemptable z' and custom
machine types so let's launch in first
on on the the first use case which is
optimizing and taking full advantage of
discounts starting point there most of
us are familiar with what's probably the
oldest and most familiar discount scheme
out there it's from Amazon Web Services
called reserved instances and many of
you may be familiar but just quick
refresher there are many types of these
but to start with standard reserved
instances you basically in order to get
a discount you pick up specific size of
instance in a specific instance family
in a particular region and commit to
either a year or three years to gain
that discount and they also have a
family of our eyes called convertible
our eyes and it's important to note the
discount is lower there and it's only
available with a three-year commitment
so what we find among customers in this
RI world is actually a lot of resistance
people struggle with this and the reason
they struggle with it is pretty simple
it's because they're being asked to
predict the future and quite often the
work
loads that they're dealing with the apps
that they're dealing with and the
approaches they're taking to development
test and production in the cloud aren't
that predictable and so you see some of
the reasons listed here I'm not sure if
I might change architectures we're not
sure what might happen to the
utilization of our app there may be new
types of instances coming with bigger
discounts so there's fear of making a
commitment that you're not going to
fully use and there's a lack of
flexibility that causes hesitation so
the reality is really that in many apps
and many many workloads you're actually
dealing with constant change the
approach to development and test etc is
evolving your architecture is changing
and evolving you're not sure what your
needs will be and we've often asked
ourselves wouldn't it be great if we
could get the discount but not be locked
in to these specific instance size
commitments and here's a an example of
that it's just a hypothetical example of
you know I think it's five instances on
the left maybe in the future what you're
using now needs to change to that eight
instance model where in this case you're
using smaller instances and distributing
the workload more wouldn't it be great
if you could get that well actually this
is just another description of what's
been announced this week with committed
use discount and again you can get some
of that with convertible our eyes but
you're committed to three years which in
our experience is really quite a long
time frame for most customers let's take
a look at a specific example this is an
anonymized real customer usage with cost
on the vertical and overtime on the
horizontal and you can see that there's
a pretty steady base usage there that's
growing slightly and then during
weekdays some transient usage that's
Devon test in this example so if we map
this to both providers comparing AWS and
Google on the AWS side what we would
recommend
we happen to know this customer is using
about 80% of those instances our
production and about 50% for Devin test
we would recommend if they're having to
lock in and commit to standard our eyes
we'd say why don't you limit your
exposure there to 65% in order to gain
savings but leave yourself some
flexibility for change if you're going
to commit to convertible our eyes go
ahead and go up to 90 percent so that's
what our recommendation would typically
be over a long experience helping
customers save money take a look at that
on Google with Google pricing it's
pretty much a no-brainer with a new
committed use discount just go ahead and
take 90% of it and buy into that with a
committed use discount because there's
no flexibility trade-off and let the
sustained use discount with the inferred
instance capability that was that Paul
mentioned earlier take care of the rest
that's going to automatically fit the
pieces together of the transient uses
into the upmost optimal cost savings for
you if we map that on to actual dollars
what you see here we've done the kelps
I'm not going to go through every detail
there but we did map out three different
levels with the assumptions that I
mentioned about 50 and 80 percent
averaging out so a standard rri one year
reserved instance approach on the right
hand side you can see you're getting 21
percent savings by using that mechanism
three-year standard RI 39 percent and
the more comparable three year
convertible RI is 34 percent so what
we're gonna look at here to keep it
apples to apples and try and match some
of the flexibility in the in the in the
Google pricing scheme that allows you to
shift instance sizes and families and so
on we're gonna map the first one which
is a one-year and the the third one
which is a three-year convertible here's
what that looks like on Google 35%
the one year which represents 28% better
savings than the AWS one-year standard
are I approach in this example and then
on three-year 52% savings which
represents a 35 percent improvement over
AWS three-year convertibles if you
summarize all of that into a single
chart here's what you're looking at on
one year you have better pricing on
three year you have better pricing than
both the full three-year without
convertible and a three year with
convertible and other important points
to remember is that on the one year you
still with committed use you still get
flexibility so that's an advantage on
flexibility whether its one-year or
three-year you also get more ease of use
because it's important to remember with
the convertible our eyes on AWS
you still need to track your usage and
make a special request to AWS to assign
an instance to the convertible RI you've
bought in the Google scheme all of that
happens automatically and then of course
the final and third point is it's just
less expensive so we think that's pretty
groundbreaking and pretty compelling the
second use case was Devon test workloads
so this is a starting point we are
talking about savings here and this
doesn't really apply to one cloud or
another this applies to any cloud that
you run on and actually I'll admit might
be obvious to you it was a little bit of
a iOpener for me years ago when I first
looked at it if you limit your usage on
your workload to only say 12 hours a day
five days a week you're actually saving
65% and that's a key thing that we help
people with with automation in the rest
of the right scale platform is to
schedule scheduled run times that don't
run 24/7 when they don't need to Paul
mentioned a whole bunch of workloads I
think one of the most common is Devon
test that we are that we're talking
about here so when we map that to the
preemptable model
that Paul talked about we've got four
levels there if you run with sustained
only you see the first price around
67,000 if you commit to a portion of
that you can achieve a 9% savings with
the committed use discount if you start
mixing committed with preemptable x' and
if you can have a Devon test workflow
that is tolerant of instances being
taken away and maybe it's just the loss
of a little time for you versus loss of
any data if your dev test flow allows
for that which means think about that
that's a good thing
you could save 40% by splitting half in
half and if you're able to put all of
that Devon tests onto preemptable it's a
70% savings so there is an analogue here
with Amazon's
spot instance market difference being
that in that market it is a market and
you need to bid and so you're not
guaranteed a price you can get pretty
great savings but here you're guaranteed
a price you know what you'll be paying
in this model the last use case I wanted
to share was around right sizing using
custom machine types this is a
screenshot of a part of right scale on
cost analytics that we call the
utilization report and what you see here
along the horizontal axis is how much
memory utilization there is on an
instance so farther to the right more
memory farther up vertically on the
graph more CPU utilization the instances
or VMs are represented by the circles
and the size of the circle is the cost
that you're paying for that VM so
immediately with a single blink your eye
can go to the lower left and go I'm
paying for stuff that I'm not using
there and that's pretty pretty great to
be able to see now sometimes that's on
purpose for example you might have a
warm spare hot spare sitting there for
some sort of disaster recovery scenario
so it might be on purpose but in many
cases it's not and when we
work with customers we say you know in
that very lower left
that's a candidate for downsizing a
t-shirt size or two with this the
standard predefined vm's types but more
importantly when we're talking about
custom machine types in the upper left
that's an example of VMS where the cpu
utilization is pretty reasonably high
but not the memory so you might want to
dial in a custom machine type that
lowered the memory requirement same
applies in the lower right just the
converse high memory utilization low CPU
so here's another example let's say you
needed four CPUs and 20 gigs in a
machine size standard predefined
VMs on both AWS and Google you'd have to
get an 8 CPU and 30 gigabyte and you can
see what the pricing is there and I
think that Google pricing is updated for
the announcements this week but if
you're able to dial in a custom vm in
this example you save even more you're
able to save 42 percent over the
standard predefined size on Google and
64 percent over the standard predefined
size on AWS so that's a quick tour of
these three approaches to savings and I
think the bottom line is that with the
announcements you've heard this week as
well as other mechanisms Google's had in
place for pricing they've pretty much
upped the ante and taken the lead in the
cloud provider space for offering very
customer friendly pricing so we'll just
say compliments to the whole Google
cloud team we're very impressed with
that and thank you for making all of
this a whole lot easier for us customers
out there by the way if you're
interested in learning more about right
scale and Paul why don't you start
coming back up here to because we'll do
some Q&A we do have a booth here
downstairs we also are doing a webinar I
think the two of us together later this
month with a deeper dive on March 23rd
you can also get that state of the cloud
report that I referred to earlier off of
our
side
[Music]
you